all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and man let me show you something
man let me show you something this video
is going to get rowdy I'm just I'm
letting you all know right now it's
about to pop off okay so well first
thing first if you didn't watch the last
video time out time out if you didn't
watch the last video pause this video go
back and watch the last video and then
come back and finish this video so in
the last video that we did right name of
the Submariner had basically killed the
king of the newly discovered Atlantean
territory now we are going to learn more
about these guys right so you're not
gonna have to worry about feeling left
out or anything like that just make sure
you go back and watch the last video so
the thing about this is that in in this
whole event right after he killed the
king these These Old atlanteans
basically turn on Namor and all of his
forces and Susan storm is trying to
figure out why right she's like why in
the world would name all the Submariner
do this right like basically kill the
king of a newly discovered tribe in
their own kingdom surrounded by their
own forces and that's when she realized
Namor had planned all of this now here's
the thing man name of the Submariner in
the MCU he's cool and honestly I never
cared about name all the Submariner
until we got to the MCU I'll take that
back there were only two times I ever
like name all the Submariner one was
during this story in Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four and the other one wasn't
Jonathan hickory's Avengers and New
Avengers oh my God I love that story but
it was during that story right that's
where Namor is at his most badass that
and probably Avengers vs X-Men 2. those
three stories but like this is one of
those times when he's amazing so Susan
storm figured out what was going on did
Neymar killing the King was not just
done arbitrarily as a king himself he
realizes that if there is no King to
give orders the things will lead to a
state of panic so while Namor had killed
the king what he had also instructed was
for his forces from Atlantis to attack
this new kingdom so literally Neymar
kills the king the Army comes rolling in
and Pops off they start killing
everybody now it doesn't last long and
the reason why is because once Susan
storm realizes what happens she pops out
of Force Shield and basically keeps like
the entire Kingdom protected now here's
one of the things that I want you to
want you to keep this in about your head
it's not going to become important now
but Susan Storm's force field is going
to become like the thing that separates
what is an effect every superhero on
Earth from imminent Doom right like like
just destruction death chaos pandemonium
she's gonna be like the sole line of
defense until the reinforcements come
and sauce
when those reinforcements come man nah
dude I can't wait till we get to that
part of the story that is so
ridiculously good so Susan storm
basically keeps the whole place
protected I'm sorry I'm so excited
people but it is an exciting story it is
an exciting story and I'm so amped up
about this so Susan storm keeps
everything protected right keeps these
guys safe but what ends up going on is
she actually just holds this force field
for like a day now over the years in
Marvel Comics in all seriousness here
over the years the Marvel Comics Susan
Storm's force field has become more and
more powerful as time has gone on in the
sense that when she was malice right so
she was just like a crazy woman that her
powers were kind of Amplified and a lot
of the ability of her to maintain a
force field for prolonged amounts of
time and to maintain a huge force field
for a lengthy period of time that kind
of thing maintained and so what Jonathan
Hickman is doing is basically building
on a lot of the Susan storm storytelling
that's been done in the Fantastic Four
Comics over the years Mark Miller John
Byrne those guys and just kind of
bringing it all together here in this
story so again it's one of those things
I'm really hoping they do her justice in
the MCU because I'm gonna tell you right
now man people underestimate how
powerful Susan storm is and so she's one
of those characters that's cool but
because of the fact that Namor is
currently being held prisoner because
his armies cannot penetrate The Shield
of Susan storm Susan's responses bring
him to me now one of the reasons why
Susan does this is because as we know
Nimble the Submariner man he's got it
down bad for Susan storm man like he's
down bad for Susan storm this guy man
he's just holding out he's just holding
against hope that she gets tired of Reed
Richards and she ends up banging him
instead which is actually what happened
in the Ultimate Universe it was pretty
amazing but the thing about this is that
that ultimately Neymar spills the the
beams to Susan and he tells her what's
going on here is not what you think it
is in the days of old Atlantis right
eons and eons ago even before Neymar the
Submariner was even born right like
after after Atlantis had basically
fallen during the Great cataclysm when
it had been destroyed by the celestials
hence another reason why you should
pause this video go back and watch the
last video and then come back and
continue this video so during that point
in time that what had happened is that
these old atlanteans had Arisen as what
were in effect a scourge of the ocean
right that what they couldn't take or
conquer they would consume right they
were literally like a parasite right
just like a virus traveling around the
ocean and just consuming everything in
its path and so war broke out between
basically namor's version of the
atlanteans and these old atlanteans now
initially they were believed to have
been destroyed and and eradicated and
that was it and all knowledge of their
existence was stricken from the record
books but as we know now some of them
survived down in the Antarctic and under
vostok Lake right where vostok station
is basically being built or operating or
whatever but the thing about this is
that what what Namor says is like the
way these guys work is they either
they're discovered or whatever it is but
they show up on the scene and then they
present themselves as people who are
trying to do cool things right they're
on a mission of peace or something along
those lines and they have a person who
stands in as their Emissary from a
particular Kingdom right so in this
instance it is the kingdom of Earth
which Susan storm is like the Emissary
for the kingdom of Earth and then you
have these old atlanteans and you have
the new atlanteans the way they work is
they have the Emissary in this instance
Susan storm basically create a kind of
uh I guess a meeting place whereby this
group meets with this other Kingdom with
nameor's people the way it's supposed to
go down according to these old
atlanteans the way they do things is
Susan storm will serve as a vector
everybody will let their guard down then
they attack and like they basically take
catch everybody off guard they kill
Namor they kill all the atlanteans so on
and so forth they're the only ones left
and then they sacrifice Susan storm they
kill her and then it would allow them
basically dominion over the ocean Namor
knowing their history and knowing what
they're about immediately attack them
and that's why he did what he did now
the kicker to all this is that Susan
storm asked the question well how do you
know they haven't changed it's been
hundreds of thousands of years what
makes you think they're the same and so
what ends up going on here is that Susan
goes to meet with the old atlanteans
spills the beans and asks the question
is what Namor told me true the response
is no it's not we're this we're not the
same people that we used to be things
are different now and because Neymar had
killed the king what they say is we're
too young to rule which means you Susan
storm are now the steward of this old
Atlantean Kingdom you rule until we're
old enough to take the throne ourselves
which means now they're under the
protection of Susan storm once that
happens Neymar is like no they have to
go Susan storm overpowers Neymar and
then says no these people are under my
protection I'm going home if any harm
comes to them we will eradicate new
Atlantis like we'll destroy you Neymar
and your kingdom have no Illusions son
do do not be confused about your place
in the bigger picture we will kill you
Neymar we will destroy you and if you
don't think that I have the ability to I
promise you I can right I'll open a
force field in your brain that'll shut
off oxygen to it and that'll be the
story of you the guy who was stupid
enough to believe that he could kill
Susan storm so here's the thing right
it's the coolest thing so at this point
we switch over to Galactus right we
switch over to Galactus now again in the
last video what we had was Galactus
basically the body of his future self
being discovered by the Silver Surfer
Silver Surfer went and told Galactus and
then Rock Galactus to Earth and so what
this did is it led to Reed Richards
spilling the beans and saying in the
future basically the sun ends up
essentially going out right or at least
you know it doesn't let off as much heat
as it used to like something was
artificially draining the energy from
that sun when that happened essentially
the Earth's superheroes captured you
Galactus and they used your body as a
time machine and brought and wanted to
bring their people back to the past you
died in the process but they set up Res
residents on New Earth which orbits out
there in a black hole or near a black
hole somewhere and so ultimately
Galactus grabbed Reed Richards and then
they're on their way to New Earth but
again one of the things we talked about
the last video is that Galactus wanted
to get the hell out of Earth as fast as
humanly possible because what he didn't
want to do was risk a conflict with
Franklin Richards because that's what he
tells Reed your son's powers are back
read and it scares the [ __ ] out of me so
like I got I got Adam I got out of Earth
as fast as I can a little kid with the
power to alter reality and here's the
thing to understand this fear isn't
coming out of nowhere right those are
the guys who are familiar with the
history between Franklin Richards and
Galactus I mean during the old Abraxas
Saga right when galatis died and abraxis
the multiversal representation of
Destruction basically he was a cosmic
entity that Marvel got rid of super fast
but when he emerged Franklin Richards
resurrected Galactus from the dead right
and then they used the ultimate
nullifier to destroy Abraxas Franklin's
ridiculously powerful and he's a little
kid that can't fully control his power
so essentially what could happen is
Galactus could spark a fight with
Franklin Richards and Franklin could use
his powers to turn Galactus into a giant
bowl of jello and there's nothing
Galactus could do about it that's how
powerful Franklin Richards is man that
kid is broken that's why Galactus bailed
as fast as he could but once they end up
arriving at New Earth Galactus asked the
all-encompassing question right if the
people in the future on Earth use my
body as a time machine to come back to
the past in order to keep themselves
alive because the sun is failing is
there a way for you to stop that Reed is
there a way for you to keep your son
operating so that they don't need to
kill me in the future to come back to
the past otherwise this will just be a
cycle right literally my days are
numbered like I can count how many days
I have left until I ultimately die is
there a way to keep that from happening
now read Harkens back to his time with
the Council of reads which is why I told
you guys everything that Jonathan
Hickman does is important everything he
writes is important it all comes back in
some form or fashion remember in that
initial story that first story arc that
we covered we'd learned to perform
surgery on a son and that's what he
hearkens back to and says yes I think I
can keep our sun protected I think I can
find a way to ensure it doesn't die out
and that the citizens on Earth don't
need to use your body as a time machine
and so ultimately Galactus says okay
fine then you do what you need to read
but so will I right and he's just like I
hunger so literally Galactus is going to
destroy new Earth now when that happens
one of the things to know is that Ted
Castle along with Alyssa Moy the ones
who basically built new Earth in the
process and Alyssa Moy betrayed Ted
castle and using it as a way to bring
all these people from the future here
that they're just kind of like no this
can't be done but one of the other
things to know that would have kind of
gone on here behind the scenes is that
the Alyssa Moy that we see here now is
not the original human Alyssa Moy right
that was the thing that we covered is
that when Ted castle and Alyssa Moy were
building new Earth they were building it
as what was in effect like a safe haven
right if something happened to Earth and
it became unhabitable or uninhabitable
the citizens of of Earth could basically
take up on New Earth but what ended up
going on is that it was revealed that
Ted Castle was actually using it for the
super rich right the ultra Rich would be
able to exist on New Earth and everybody
else would just be left to die on Earth
and that would basically be it Alyssa
Moy turned against him but Alyssa Moy
was killed and so what ended up going on
here is that Ted Castle had actually
built new a new version of Alyssa Moore
right like a cyborg computerized version
not only that what also goes on here at
least what Reid learns that wasn't
readily made available to us is that the
original Alyssa Moy is kind of alive but
not really but she's more than kind of a
catatonic State they quite literally all
the people who were walking around New
Earth right now they're not really human
beings in the traditional sense that
they're more or less just kind of
automatons right robots but the
Consciousness the mental backups of
those human beings had basically been
stored in the head of the actual Alyssa
Moy which physically seems to be the
case too which is why her or her head is
just so gigantic but they ultimately
have to teleport her away right because
what Ted Castle realized is the human
brain can store far more information
than a computer can not only that the
human brain is actually more conducive
to to basically storing human thoughts
and Concepts than like a hard drive or
anything along those lines plus it would
draw a lot of attention if this guy was
building like this giant machine that
was gonna essentially house everybody
here he could do this with Alyssa Moy in
secret and nobody on Earth would truly
know what was going on but once Reed
learns the realization he's like okay uh
something's not right here right like
something's not right about what's going
on not just with Alyssa Moy but with
Galactus and what you end up having is
basically LightWave who again is from
the future and was at one point a Herald
of Galactus who says like my former
Master's conversation rate is much
higher than normal Galactus is not
trying to consume the world read it's
why he hasn't hasn't constructed his
world-consuming machine because that's
what Galactus always does he shows up on
a world he basically builds his machine
to consume everything on on Earth or
consume the source of the earth's
earth's energy or at least the planet's
energy and then of course the planets
destroyed in the process light wave is
like you'll notice he's not doing that
read the reality here is that Galactus
does not wish to consume new Earth
Galactus wants to destroy it like he
wants to eradicate it because we built
this as an ark to get us here and the
reality is we killed Galactus in the
process read this is nothing more than
Petty Vengeance that's really all it is
Galactus is pissed off that we killed
him in the future in order to get here
so he's going to destroy this place now
and that's basically going to be it it's
the closest he can get to revenge and so
again while that goes on right while
they're basically trying to evacuate new
world what we do ladies and gentlemen
what we do ladies and gentlemen we
switch over to the Baxter building we
switch over to the Baxter building and
what is arguably one of the greatest
moments in Fantastic Four history I told
you ladies and gentlemen the ending of
this video was gonna be lit and I
guarantee I'm gonna lose my voice by the
time this video is done okay so one of
the things that we had talked about
before is that on Earth you had what was
called The Cult of the negative zone now
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with Marvel Comics the negative
zone is a place that exists out in the
Multiverse but there's only one Negative
Zone across the whole Multiverse and it
literally exists as a hallway of doors
so you could show up from like like
people from the main Marvel Universe
could show up in the negative Zone and
meet people from an alternate reality
and in fact that's happened before right
that's that's happened in Marvel Comics
before and so one of the things that
went on here is that in the negative
Zone you have a nihilus he's basically a
guy who just believes life is
meaningless and all that kind of stuff
so essentially anybody on on Reddit
right that's basically kind of how he's
like he's like the most steadfast
definition of a redditor right he's just
a nihilist and so what this does or at
least what it did do in Marvel Comics is
it led to him invading the main Marvel
Universe and basically eradicating
almost all life right like it's nuts
Annihilation the story arc where that
happened it literally opened up with
like Peter Quill Star-Lord and Richard
writer Nova and the citizens of the
universe just fleeing for their [ __ ]
lives that's literally all it was right
just them just trying to lift that's how
the story opens right like they're
already losing it's it's just it's God
it was a phenomenal story fortunately we
covered it which you're welcome to check
out after the end of this video but the
thing about it is that that once he was
defeated and confined back to the
negative Zone this led to the cult of
the Negative Zone basically being
members of the of the the Negative Zone
itself right so like annihilus's forces
masquerading as human beings and trying
to find a way into the Baxter building
and the reason why is because in their
Baxter building is the only known portal
in the universe where you can access the
Negative Zone and it's been that way
ever since the old school stories of the
Fantastic Four they've always had the
portal there right you can always go in
and out of the Negative Zone if you
choose to and so the cult of the
Negative Zone was literally trying to
trying to get in well they finally have
now once they get into the Baxter
building keep in mind there's only a
handful of people here Reed Richards is
in space right you got Susan storm down
in the ocean dealing with everything
with Namor and old Atlantis so what you
have is Johnny Storm you have Ben Grimm
you've got Franklin Valeria and the
Future Foundation right these young kids
and while these kids are highly
intelligent they all have different
powers and so on they haven't been truly
trained in how to use their abilities
neither has Franklin even right
Franklin's not the most capable person
to use his powers that's changing and in
fact it's changing right now we just
haven't covered it yet something I want
you guys to be aware of and actually
we're going to cover this once once we
get done with the three story arc we're
gonna jump into a comic book line that
was written by Hickman that also joined
the Fantastic Four it was called Future
Foundation it's literally Franklin
learning how to use his powers and it's
awesome right like he creates like whole
universes and [ __ ] it's some of the
coolest things that you're ever gonna
see right it's just it's the coolest
stuff but what ends up going on is that
Franklin again not fully tutored in how
to use his abilities he uses them where
they can when he can but there isn't a
whole lot doing that right also remember
Ben Grimm basically lost his his thing
for one right he's back in his human
form so there's only so much he can do
now eventually his form starts to return
right he starts to turn back into his
Rocky self but the thing about this is
the cult is invading at a fever pitch
and it's literally all they can do to
hold off right to hold off these forces
because remember the forces of the
negative zone right the forces of an
eyeless they conquered Galactus the
Silver Surfer I mean pretty much
everybody fell before them so they're
only able to do so much the problem with
this is that while these forces while
you have like Johnny Storm and Franklin
and Ben and all those guys facing off
against these guys the other half of the
force goes to the negative Zone portal
and when they do they blow it open right
they literally open the Negative Zone
portal which allows the forces of
annihilus to start making their way
there and to start pouring in now you do
get this really cool moment where like
Franklin just sort of amps UPS his
powers and then incinerates a huge chunk
of these Annihilation wave forces but
there's only so much that he can do
right because again he's not fully
trained so he is able to hold them at
Bay so the decision is made by Johnny
and Ben and Valeria in them to actually
enter through the Negative Zone portal
and to take out the forces of of
annihilus as best they can before they
can even get to the portal in the first
place right so fighting on their
territory now once they get in there you
do see some cool stuff right I mean like
there's literally this moment where you
have like Johnny Storm just like
blasting fire in One Direction
Franklin's just like putting off huge
amounts of energy in another but then
you've got like Ben Grimm firing off
this just insane gun but one of the
things to remember is that the forces of
annihilist number in the trillions right
technically in the billions right it's
just it's a huge overwhelming Force this
is it's just not done by conceivable
standards and so while these guys the
Future Foundation aren't able to hold
them off momentarily what this does is
it gives them a kind of reprieve but
then they suddenly look out to the
Horizon and they realize there's a whole
host coming right billions of guys
coming right just billions of forces
coming way more than they can hold off
and so what they end up realizing is
that the the negative zone right
analysis forces had shut down the portal
on their side all they needed was
somebody to shut down the portal on the
Baxter building side but in order to
keep the forces away right in order to
shut them down someone's got to stay in
the negative Zone someone has to stay
there while everybody else gets back to
the Baxter building shut down the portal
and then they'll shut down the portal
from the Baxter side and this is one of
the coolest things man there's one of
the coolest things in level all right
just check this out man all right so
here's the thing you guys remember the
story The the thing that we did earlier
we did a couple videos ago where Reed
was yelling at Johnny storm right see
this this is why I love doing videos in
the parts man because it all comes back
right so you remember when Reed was
talking to Johnny where Johnny was being
Reckless and so on and he said at some
point Johnny Storm you're gonna have to
figure out where you stand right when
that girl who was a member of the
Negative Zone had gotten into the Baxter
building and then temporarily opened the
portal and then Reed was started
screaming at Johnny like you could have
let the whole the whole force of
annihilus on the earth and it would have
eradicated the whole planet Johnny like
you can't be Reckless you're you're
gonna have to pick a place you're gonna
have to stand for something you can't
keep this Devil May care attitude all
the time and so this is when it comes
back because ultimately Johnny Storm
decides to stay right Johnny Storm
decides to stay behind and it's the Last
Stand of Johnny Storm this guy goes out
like a [ __ ] hero and it's like one of
the greatest things ever right so check
this out so literally Johnny stays
behind and they're just kind of like no
like we can find another way right we
can find another way Johnny you don't
have to stay and Johnny's only real
response here is when you when you get
back and when you see Reed and you see
Susan tell Reed Richards this is where I
chose to make my stand this is where I
chose to to stand for something I'm
staying here you guys need to leave
right so they ultimately end up going
back through the portal right like they
go back to the portal and literally
Johnny Storm stays there so they they
create the barrier right they establish
the barrier that the Negative Zone can't
get through and Johnny storm starts
activating the portal right the door
starts to close the door starts closing
from the other side so it's just Johnny
there by himself and there are literally
watching Johnny Storm as like an army of
like a billion forces of annihilus come
making their way over there right Ben
groom's like beating on the door right
he's like Johnny no Johnny no it's like
this was ridiculously emotional moment
right and Johnny's like you know you
don't wish it any more than I do Ben
Grimm but the reality here is like this
is how things have to be so these forces
are making their way right these forces
of knowledge are making their way Johnny
storm in the most epic [ __ ] moment ever
right turns around he's just like a
billion to one huh a billion to one you
think I'm afraid of that you think I'm
afraid of that flame on with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end massive Cliffhanger thank you
guys for watching and I will catch you
all later peace